היי, שמי Katie Beslado
אני מנהלת אסטרטגיית IBM Quantum
ומחקר יישומים. אני כאן כדי להפריך
כמה שיותר מיתוסים של מחשוב קוונטי
בשישים שניות.
אחד מהיפים שבהם הוא אמיתי לגמרי
ויש לנו מכשירים על ה-IBM Cloud שכל אחד יכול לגשת אליהם.
כן, אבל רק לדברים מסוימים שהם ממש טובים בהם —
מתמטיקה מסובכת במיוחד, כמו זו שעליה היקום רץ
אבל אם אתה רוצה לעשות גיליונות אלקטרוניים ואימיילים, תשתמש
במחשב האישי שלך.
כן, תיאורטית, אבל לא
בקרוב. אף אחד לא מייצר מחשב טוב מספיק לעשות את זה
עדיין. לעתיד הנראה לעין אנחנו בכיוון הנכון
וכשנגיע לשם, נשנה את האופן שבו אנחנו מגינים על
מידע.
לגמרי שקר. מחשבים קוונטיים
שונים באופן מהותי
ומשתמשים בחוקי הטבע כדי לעבד מידע.
ה-AI של היום רץ על מכשירים קלאסיים ישנים וטובים
אבל אנחנו מאמינים שהם ישתפו פעולה בעתיד.
לא נכון. יש לנו מערכת אקוסיסטם עצומה
של סטארטאפים, אקדמיה, מעבדות לאומיות ושותפים תעשייתיים
שמשתמשים במכשירים שלנו כל יום.
לא. מחשוב בהשראה קוונטית קיים
כבר הרבה זמן ורץ על מכשירים קלאסיים. הם
לעולם לא יממשו את ההבטחה של מחשוב קוונטי.
אם אתה רוצה מחשוב קוונטי, חייבים לעשות את זה עם מחשבים קוונטיים אמיתיים
.